[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily a
colorado husband accused of murder
allegedly threatened to shoot his wife's
lover before she disappeared why did
barry morphew take five trips to the
trash the same day suzanne morphy was
reported missing and a flute repair shop
owner turns to a life of crime you don't
sell someone else's flute and pocket
that money the woman's punishment for
stealing from her customers plus talking
to the jury makes me nervous robert
durst testifies in his murder trial the
real estate air questioned about the
mysterious disappearance of his first
wife did you intend to hurt kathy
no
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm bryan buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with a strange story out
of ohio where a once reputable flute
repair technician turned thief and scam
artists lawn crimes and janet levy is
here with the story of pat north and her
victims
brian i started covering stories about
pat north back in 2019 as i did more
stories more victims came forward and
that in part led to her being charged
with stealing from her customers many of
whom she had known for decades
there is something wrong here there is
something wrong
with the way this individual processes
the world
thinks about the world
harsh words from the prosecutor for pat
north a woman who repaired flutes for
decades but now admits pawning many of
them for cash
victims from across the country wrote to
the judge chris hawke was a longtime
customer and found her flute similar to
this one in a pawn shop i believe with
all my heart
that pat north knew that what she did
was illegal and unethical
you don't sell someone else's flute and
pocket that money north said she took
the flutes to pawn shops for safe
keeping and blamed her poor health for
her situation
i could not keep up with the interest
payments on the deposit loans
it never occurred to me
that this would happen but a former
employee said this had been going on
well before any illnesses
she did it to get the repair work
knowing that she could not meet the
deadlines she immediately charged the
credit cards
whether or not she would fix it that
week that month or even that year and
north's former partner spoke of giving
her money for years
i was in a 38-year plus-year
relationship with pat which is
characterized by a history of bullying
and gaslighting and i can't tell you the
amount of deceit
and betrayal i feel here in regards to
some musical instruments
that are sent to you a customer from
california hired a private investigator
to track down her instruments
i continued my investigation and located
eight other victims
that had been defrauded by ms north
and re-presented my case after more
customers came forward prosecutors filed
charges leading to her sentencing on a
felony count
there are
victims whose lives have been destroyed
because of this defendant
the judge ordered pat north to spend
five years on community
control which is also known as probation
she also has to get a full-time job and
pay back about 90 000
to many of her customers she was also
ordered to get a mental health
evaluation followed by mental health
treatment
brian thanks angeannette joining us
today is retired detective and swat
member lisa lockwood and terry austin
lisa crazy story but what about the
victims if she pawned off a person's
flute and someone bought it can the
police get that flute back to the right
person
it's not necessarily easy to do that if
records were not kept a lot of times
across the nation in pawn shops there
are regulations that require
the seller to actually give their
drivers lice information to the to the
pawn shop and then they keep records of
that there are no records of the buyers
per se and that's if they are doing what
they're supposed to legally a lot of
times pawn shops don't even get that
information and end up selling it on the
side so it's not an easy feat the
private investigator took it a step
further than police did in this
particular case and was able to put the
case together to show that there were
eight other victims and in some cases
they were able to get a few of those
flutes back absolutely a lot of digging
into this story led us to this point
speaking of digging in terry anjanette
won't say it so i guess you and i will
angina is the one who didn't just report
on this but her reporting led to more
people coming forward and led to an
indictment here we may not be here but
for anjanet so your reaction to seeing
how the story started and now ended
you know what brian i have always said
that we are very lucky to have angenette
as a correspondent for law and crime
this is not the first time she's
investigated something and stuck to the
story to make sure that she gets to the
end and bring it to the light
and this case in particular it took some
persistent investigation to get down to
the bottom of what exactly occurred this
is a very personal crime when you have
an individual that you've entrusted with
your music and with your instrument and
you've known this individual for so many
years so i think kudos to angenette
kudos to the investigators and i'm glad
we finally got to the bottom of this and
that there was some justice for the
victims of this crime couldn't agree
more terry
lucky honored proud and jeanette let's
go back to you now what was pat north
doing with all this money
well brian and terry first of all you
are very kind and very generous so thank
you for all of your kind words but
really what she was doing with the money
is still the 64 million dollar question
nobody knows and you know the police
spent a lot of time going through her
banking records they went through all of
her financial records at the flute
repair shop where she was operating
so nobody really knows what was going on
a lot of people think she was just a
really bad businesswoman but she was
putting people off for months and months
and in some cases years and giving them
their instruments back or their money
and it was very rare that she did either
well here's hoping that that restitution
or the flutes at the very least get back
to the original owners thank you
everyone turning now to more top legal
news former reality tv star josh duggar
wants more information about officers
involved in his arrest on child porn
charges
duggar was part of the show 19 kids and
counting on tlc he's asking a federal
judge to order prosecutors to turn over
information about some of the officers
who arrested him and downloaded files
from his laptop federal prosecutors call
it a fishing expedition and say the
information is non-existent or
immaterial to the defense duggar has
pled not guilty his trial is scheduled
for november
and in new york the jury has been
selected for the trial of r b singer r
kelly kelly was arrested in july 2019 on
federal charges of sexual assault human
trafficking and child pornography seven
men and five women will deliberate r
kelly's fate their identities are
anonymous but one of the men reportedly
has a friend in bill cosby's family and
another mistook r kelly for the
cartoonist r crum opening statements are
set to begin next wednesday nearly two
years after his arrest
still ahead on law and crime daily new
evidence revealed in the case of suzanne
morphy's disappearance but first robert
durst is back on the stand the real
estate heirs continued direct
examination as he denies killing his
best friend the questions now turn to
the disappearance of his wife next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back robert durst is back on the
stand for a second day pleading his case
that he didn't murder his best friend
nor his first wife
durst is on trial for the december 2000
murder of his best friend susan berman
but prosecutors also accused the real
estate heir of murdering his first wife
kathy in 1982.
kathy's body was never found and durst
is not charged in her case on the stand
durr says he told kathy he never wanted
to have children and asked her to get an
abortion when she became pregnant
well i'm about a year
she woke up one morning
and she had what she knew was morning
sickness
because she had watched her three big
sisters go through it
was there a big argument about it or was
it no there was no big argument about it
i took the train to the city
i got a call from kathy
and she said bobby
i want to have this baby
and i said i do not want to have a baby
and she said okay i'll go along with
that
she said she'd looked into
places where she would get it done and
there was a little clinic
right in downtown katona
and she wanted me to come home and bring
her to the clinic
did you do that i did that
dur says kathy's friends encouraged her
to use drugs apparently throwing coke
and veggie parties he says around that
time in 1981 he learned kathy's had
retained her own lawyer
this is a matrimonial lawyer
do you want a divorce
no she does not want a divorce
have you met somebody
no i have not met somebody
was it a mystery to you as to why
she has this matrimonial lawyer at some
point
i decided that i needed to have a
matrimonial lawyer if kathy had a
matrimonial lawyer even though i had no
idea
what it was that was a problem
did you want a divorce
no had you even thought about a divorce
never
never
thought about a divorce
ever thought about problems in my
marriage
i was happy with my marriage but when
did you learn that you had a romantic
affair with another man
when
i think the first time
i came to accept
that she had had an affair
was
in october
of 1981.
did you
have other affairs
that is with other women
that's when i started
let's bring back retired detective and
swat member lisa lockwood and terry
austin terry why is this testimony about
durst's relationship with kathy so
important
you know they spent a lot of time
talking about the relationship with
kathy i think they're trying to
establish a couple of things first and
foremost is the fact that durst is not
mean and cold and he had a good
relationship with his wife kathy he
talked about how both of them agreed
they didn't want to have children how he
supported her throughout her application
for medical school he contributed mostly
to the joint account he even talked
about a month together that they spent
in greece so they're trying to establish
he had no reason to kill her the other
issue is the drug use i think there's a
bit of blaming the victim here the fact
that she had an affair so maybe she just
left on her own ultimately brian i think
they're trying to show he didn't kill
kathy though why would he kill susan
berman exactly lisa a few people have
commented on dursa's let's say charisma
when he testifies as a retired detective
i'm assuming you see through that all so
what do you see when durst testifies
so think about how many times he's been
interviewed we've got hours and hours of
footage from the prosecution from past
cases from morris black from him
testifying from the movie the jinx
from all good things he loves to talk no
doubt about it but when i look at it i
don't see it as charisma i see it as a
villainous character similar to lost in
space dr smith somebody who is
manipulative and i'm
grateful that all of that did come out
in the movies and the jury was able to
see the part of him including the
domestic violence against kathy that was
proven and then also the abortion and in
in his mind it wasn't forced it was
their decision absolutely thank you both
lisa lockwood seeing through all it all
through seeing through it all sorry
coming up on law and crime daily updates
on the disappearance of suzanne murphy
how multiple trips to a garbage could be
incriminating to her husband
plus the family of a man convicted of
murdering a sheriff's deputy asked the
jury for mercy does stephen wiggins
deserve the death penalty for lighting a
deputy's body on fire
[Music]
welcome back text messages between a
missing colorado woman and her husband
who's charged with her murder reveal
their marriage was on the rocks
morpheus texted her husband saying she
was done with their marriage four days
later she disappeared a hearing is
underway to see whether there's enough
evidence for barry morphy to stand trial
prosecutors revealed suzanne and another
man were having an affair at the time
she disappeared her body has never been
found an fbi agent testified barry took
five trips to get rid of garbage and
stayed in a hotel the day suzanne went
missing he claims he was working on a
construction job even though nobody's
allowed to work on a sunday in the city
of bloomfield colorado
back with us as retired detective and
swap member lisa lockwood and co-host
terry austin terry five trash runs the
day suzanne morpheus of disappearance
but her body was never found so
is this just really odd or is it
criminal
well it is really odd brian but it could
be criminal if there's other
incriminating evidence and we know
already from this preliminary hearing
that there is some discriminating
evidence we know their phone records are
showing that they may have been arguing
and fighting in the house running around
after suzanne obviously there's a motive
here we know that barry actually
threatened suzanne's boyfriend with you
know mutilating him or at least saying
he would do that so i think there's
other evidence here and i think it could
lead to moving this case on to a
full-blown trial of course and that's
exactly what the judge is trying to
measure here the volume as well as the
quality of the evidence lisa how do you
think the investigation into more for
you went based on what you've heard so
far
it's really challenging brian when you
don't have a body no question about it
and we had this case it's reminiscent of
jennifer doulos and fotus dulos who
ended up killing himself before there
was any chance of finding the body or
finding out if he was guilty but we do
know that there was strife in the
marriage in both cases that draws a
parallel somebody who was threatening to
leave somebody else and somebody who
didn't want to let go of that individual
so this is a very similar case but i do
believe they did a great job in the
forensic telephones records and actually
getting video footage of him doing those
five separate uh garbage
dumps in that case and it was the same
thing with jennifer and photos doulos
yeah and also that whole dr jekyll and
hyde situation where they were talking
about men who have almost like split
personalities when it comes to dealing
with their wives there's another
similarity thank you both when we come
back inside the tennessee courtroom
where a man convicted of shooting and
killing a deputy is asking a jury to
spare him from the death penalty the
testimony after the break
welcome back a tennessee jury is
continuing to hear evidence in the
penalty phase for a man convicted of
killing a cop now facing either life in
prison or the death penalty
stephen wiggins was found guilty of
fatally shooting dickinson sergeant
daniel baker and lighting baker's body
on fire wiggins stole baker's patrol
vehicle pretended to be baker over the
radio and said he shot baker point blank
because quote it's like a dog you don't
let it suffer defense attorneys say
wiggins has brain damage from being
beaten as a young child which doesn't
excuse his actions but should be
considered as a possible reason to vote
against execution
mr wiggins suffers from a neurocognitive
disorder brain damage
likely he was born this way and has
resulted in seizures hallucinations
reduced ability to reach social cues
irritability impulsivity and emotional
dysregulation
kind of in a nutshell those are the ways
in which his various brain areas have
impacted him
while brain damage is not curable
symptoms like this are treatable
he is being treated with medications
that he was not taking on the street
because he couldn't afford it
as well as he's in a structured
environment and he's done very well and
so it's showing in fact that he can have
a good response with medication and
being in a structured environment uh and
and so there is treatment available
there's good treatment available and
he's responding to it
wiggins declined to take the stand in
his own defense but the defense did call
his mother and brother to talk about
abuse wigan suffered at the hands of his
father including being beat with a
rotary phone
like most other
things it was an object
for him to use
to hit us
if he was
incredibly angry at the time he could
hit stephen anywhere but
every day all day he would hit stephen
in the head
and
would he just pop him in the head or
would he hit him with enough
with some force
it varied
sometimes it was just a pop and
sometimes it was a full
force
i remembered him
dragging me by my hair
all the way out of the house across the
porch
and down the steps
as the boys got older
did did scott's physical abuse of them
increase
i don't know if his
mental
problems got worse
or if he just began to enjoy it more
it just seemed to get worse and worse
and worse to the point that
anything was a weapon
there was weapons knives he's held guns
to her head
lisa the last person executed in
tennessee was in 2018 and he got the
electric chair not after a triple murder
but after he killed another person in
jail so do you think the death sentence
may be too hard for the prosecution to
get in this state
i'm not so sure in this particular case
because it's going to be based on who
makes up the jury and because it needs
to be unanimous you're going to be
looking at people's various personal
experiences that they use as a reference
whether it be religious they don't
believe in the death penalty or they
have a family member who has a mental
disorder or they themselves were abused
in some capacity will they actually
garner that sympathy based on that
situation just as a mother said that the
father had mental illness potentially he
does and he has brain damage so is he
ever going to be
a citizen that can stand up in society
at any point to have parole so i mean i
think that's the entire case that the
jury will ultimately decide on
absolutely terry do you think wiggins
made the right decision not testifying
in the penalty phase
no doubt about it brian that was the
right decision there were several issues
that witnesses established on his behalf
they put classmates on the stand all the
classmates talked about the fact that he
had trouble making friends he was a
loner he didn't dress well he smelled a
little different from the other students
but the main thing is he was bullied and
he was mistreated throughout his school
life so i think they've already
established much of what they needed
through the medical testimony and
through these classmates and so for
wigans to get up on the stand i think
would only subject him to
cross-examination and i think the jury
is going to look at him in a different
way if he actually testified they're
either going to think he's acting or you
know i don't think they're going to see
sympathy from him so this was the right
decision not to testify in my opinion
yeah i tend to agree as well all of
those witnesses you're talking about can
provide information that he probably
would have given anyways lisa terry
thank you very much for today and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you